[Music]
and where is the line news and we're
jumping over it submitted by husky 2001
or doesn't mean I'll choose the
choo-choo-choo well they took the other
one so I'm like I'm going to the other
side of husky youtubers acting as
amateur detectives call into question
the ethics of the true crime trend hmm
so do you guys know what the true crime
trend is no no I'm so behind so no you
know it's like that podcast serial
exactly back in 2014
Brendon Buffy Oh both of these programs
are following these men that are being
accused of murder and so they're just
there examining evidence to question
whether they were guilty or not okay so
that's what things are and so now
youtubers what they're doing is that
they're acting like story time videos of
one day they killed someone know like
their neighbors a murder or like my
neighbor got killed or like things like
that like they're posting up stories
like for example shake Dawson because
they mentioned him in this article here
Shane Dawson posted one that's called my
friend got life in prison and so oh wow
he's pretty much talking about motives
of a man who killed his uncle back in
2011 and so pretty much what he was
doing here is he was revealing the name
of the murder and the victim he showed
off the murderers Facebook profile and
photos and messages that the murders
tells hood friends were sending and he
also speculated about his drug use and
he showed off old footage and yearbook
photos of the murder mmm and at one
point in the video he begins to read a
message out loud from one of the
murderers friends but then he ends up
stopping himself and says I'm not gonna
put in what she said our respect for his
family and so a lot of youtubers are
making videos like this where now
there's Becky
like is this ethical you know like the
fact that they're they're talking about
like other people's families and like
private information where you don't know
how the family feels about you releasing
this information because they're not
directly involved in just like oh I know
this story exactly wouldn't it be
equivalent to daxing like just well
isn't this public information we're
gonna sense well you're you're obviously
yeah maybe that public information but
you're also putting accusations without
hard evidence I guess and then you're
you're it's like pitchfork mob they're
gonna go after them all the fans are
gonna go after them and berate them you
should public info that's why that's why
I'm like oh that was like random like I
think this guy murdered my okay got it
no that would suck there is this the end
and I will say it chained Dawson's a
buddy mine so in full disclosure but but
do you know about this no I know okay
but I've known of this trend I guess I
have recognized it but it's I just think
it's interesting because youtuber get
help to such a different standard
because people feel like they know us
personally like have you noticed that
like if you do a video say it's on a
tragedy and now you monetize this video
you guys are [ __ ] because you
monetize the tragedy and you're talking
about a tragedy and you're taking
advantage of a tragedy and you're making
money out of it but when Dateline
[ __ ] NBC talks about a murder from a
high school town they talk about the
details of the case they name all this
[ __ ] they talk they go into the
letter probably actually read the
[ __ ] thing and then like I'm we're
gonna cut the commercial we'll be right
back and they [ __ ] sell ads against
it nobody gives a sweet [ __ ] because
that's what you're used to grow up with
that it's a fact of life but because we
do it - you're sellouts your sellout
[ __ ] and you're taking advantage of
tragedy like every year on 9/11 every
Network wall-to-wall coverage is we're
playing back the planes shooting into
the [ __ ] towers and they cut to a
nestle ad so spare me spare me this
false equivalence
yeah it might be their fan base because
we we're fortunate to have dope as fans
that just understand and like they know
right now that the whole D monetization
thing is happening everyone's kind of
[ __ ] so if we just run ads on anything
jakie news or whatever on our vlogs
they're cool with it
but why wouldn't you be able to this is
what I'm saying like cuz you might have
like ten year old fans that just don't
understand that are pissed off sometimes
even Phil has to do that like Phil
Franco has to be like I'm not monetizing
this one cuz I'm gonna talk about this
person and I'm like you can you should
monetize anything you want anything you
want yeah it's your chance no difference
between you and the news media and these
guys who are making money off of it
newspaper what do you think they do they
still ads and they're [ __ ] that cuz
it's his job to report right so whether
it's a tragedy or not he's doing work he
might even do extra work because it's a
tragedy he has to do it
like within a certain period of time has
to rush he has to get the right
information stop whatever you know maybe
not even feed his baby for a minute
because he has to do this [ __ ] yeah but
see you know but see now you get called
out in the community but all these like
get people who have no talent they just
call out other youtubers for Bishop
it's true that's true they don't do
anything like a no-talent other are they
youtubers you're talking about
yeah but then that's their whole [ __ ]
thing right is that they to talk about
how other people suck yep and then they
have like a collection of losers that
like worship them that also go off and
talk about in criticize and [ __ ] people
yeah so that's the one saying I think
and then and there the first pretty bolt
to out the gate saying like you're
monetizing this Phil or Shane or whoever
or JK and you guys therefore are bad
people while they monetize those who
clearly aren't paying your bills telling
you how you should get your bills paid
you know I mean absolutely that's why I
do like our fans they're actually they
they're bigoted they probably they're
happy when we yeah yeah in support
ourselves and I love that it's like
sometime but yeah they're really great
if you're like blatantly obvious what
they're like [ __ ] yeah you're doing good
you know I like that yeah but then so
what they're talking about here though
is the fact that those both of those
shows
and making a murderer they've also been
criticized for poor ethical practices
with the families and the victims
because they consider an invasion of
their private grief and so now they're
saying that even though those shows were
criticized that at least they were made
by professional journalists and
filmmakers who had an understanding of
both media law and ethics and so there's
this British journalism lecturer who
research ethics of tragedy reporting and
so this person is things Jackie Newton
he is saying that he is kind of troubled
with this trend on YouTube talking about
this like true crime stuff because he's
saying that with the work that he's
researched the bereaved families they
understand the of well-meant that they
have with the journalists in the tragedy
and that they build up relationships
with the trusted reporters but then here
with on YouTube it's like they're not
talking to the families they're not
getting like actual facts and they're
just gossiping they're not willingly
consenting yeah you can please tell my
story it's just so happens that this
random youtuber knows the story and now
they're telling it verses like serial
they're working with the journalists
like day to day and okay cool you tell
my story and in fact I'll give you more
information on the story that seems like
what's happening but I guess in the case
of Shane Dawson that was his uncle he is
the family yes yeah but then there are
these other youtubers like one title
says my neighbor was murdered the full
story and this other one my friend is a
murderer live footage story time where
they actually use real CCTV footage of a
shooting in New York and it's like it's
just it's like ethical gray area it just
kind of shows how desperate some
youtubers are I feel like it's like
those those there's a [ __ ] story time
people are like oh I went to jail but
it's like they played Monopoly and they
were in jail for like a day they're like
there's always those shit-ass
storytellers for some reason I have
millions of followers like the titles I
was like I was great and then it's like
it's usually just like oh someone beat
me in a game so bad that they break them
in that game like that's you knowing
people fall for it they keep clicking on
it it's like I'm pregnant I thought I
was pregnant this morning I'm not
so I had morning sickness I thought but
it wasn't I had a weird burrito yeah oh
it's a crazy [ __ ] title and it's just
like some water down [ __ ] like your
life is really boring even in this
article they've mentioned that there was
this popular meme making fun of this
trend saying like Starbucks employees I
forgot your straw oh my god give me a
second
youtuber storytime my Starbucks barista
has Alzheimer's yeah like that [ __ ]
crazy that's really funny immature and
like they go on tours I'm like what are
they touring for telling these stories
yeah oh my god standing on stage telling
stories to these dumb idiot teenagers
they're like oh my god you're amazing
but the teenagers just want to look the
teenagers just want to see the person in
moving in person that's yeah they're not
there to [ __ ] hear anything
entertaining or anything these people
aren't trained at that and know how to
do that but so they're just there to
sign a thing and like greet the fans and
I mean it's like these little [ __ ] boy
groups who like just lip-sync yeah the
ones who look at their their boys and
looked on camera like and oh yeah and
all they do and they all live in a house
together and they all just like like
lip-sync to music they go on tour and
just like dance around a stage well
music plays and they want a leader
that's so crazy but it just shows you
that that's the demand from the fans is
not like to be entertained it's just to
see the person people are gonna continue
doing what's successful and working for
them so like if they're getting a lot of
views they're gonna continue doing that
I mean these murder mystery stories or
whatever if one person does it and it's
starting to hit as everyone else is just
gonna follow suit yeah I don't know just
don't know what the difference is
between this and the [ __ ] news I
guess because I don't respect the news
either like like as far as the way they
might work shitty [ __ ] like they're all
credible and they're just because
they're wearing suits yeah you know
because they talked to two sources that
maybe later on bomb out on the story
like like I don't know man and then and
then and then yeah you're right they
will post up with the family and like be
all like you know oh we're gonna get
this right and then they [ __ ] take a
[ __ ] on the family's head
so who knows like look at John and Patsy
Ramsey dude they got raped through the
[ __ ] mud while all these journalists
were building rapport and then like so
yeah [ __ ] like these people will shoot
you in the back for 20 bucks like it's
all for the ratings exactly you're just
jealous because some kid in the [ __ ]
bedroom is getting more views and it's
only for the Bradys what do you think
Dateline NBC every single week is about
rape or about some college town murder
or about it's always the most exciting
stories it's like oh we have the story
of this kid who's in a wheelchair like
in Alameda County and it's like now
that's not sexy it's so shitty no even
for us when we do regular ass news like
that nobody cares nobody we could we
could make the phone it could be the
funnest conversation but no one clicks
on that yeah I don't want to keep doing
[ __ ] somebody got raped and murdered
news write it so [ __ ] because those
reporters will like just take advantage
of their grief like so little eat your
boy how do you feel about your mom
getting blown in the face by a shotgun
make you feel you know like you think's
a no you're trying to get them to cry
and [ __ ] then the people go oh did mommy
say anything to you before she put the
shotgun in her mouth right like it's
that's credible journalism right there
but exactly like give me a break these
people are sharp if you would do this
you went to school for it yeah so she
and Dawson can't talk about how like a
[ __ ] home town murder like I don't
know but I don't know what the
difference is good I think
either way it's [ __ ] up waiting
people's grief whether it's on YouTube
or news or whatever it's [ __ ] up I
don't think it's I don't think it is
that though I think they're I think just
reporting on something is not
necessarily exploiting some thing you
know I'm saying like my age is telling
the story it's just telling a story and
then of course you have to make a living
yeah like I'm not criticizing the news
for running ads either anymore that I'm
criticizing like schoener and youtuber
through running ads like it's the same
thing I think telling stories fine just
don't [ __ ] go and harass the family
and like egg on like shitty ass
reactions from the family you know or
like throw them under the bus or
anything
reporting spikes people do the news just
don't be shitty about it
[Music]